The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last
time we were talking
about descending auditory
pathways and the brainstem
reflexes, which
are, in some sense,
part of those
descending pathways.
And especially how
they protect our sense
of hearing from damage.
So I had a question
about subway noise
on the Red Line in Boston.
And I was asking
around at my hospital
and nobody seems to
have measured it.
But I saw online that there
were some measurements
of subway noise
in New York City.
And that it can
actually be damaging
if you get exposed to
it for long enough.
So there's a little news
clipping about subway noise.
So I don't ride the
Red Line very often.
I ride a commuter train
from Lincoln, where I live,
to North Station.
And when that train comes
in and puts on its brakes,
it's incredibly shrill.
And I always plug my years.
And about half the people
do and the other half
have hearing loss, I
guess, or whatever.
It's not really a
laughing matter.
So any questions from last time?
Of course, the brainstem
reflexes we were talking about
are also good for
other functions,
like reducing the
effects of noise masking,
allowing selective attention,
those types of functions.
I also have experimental
evidence in support of them.
So if there aren't
questions from last time,
we are going to shift
gears a little bit
and talk about something
completely different, which
is sound localization.
And so today's
roadmap is titled--
headlined-- "Sounds
Localization."
And we're going to be talking
about the kind of localization
using binaural cues,
where you have two ears.
And because you have two ears
and because sound sources
are located off your
midline for the most part,
we have some very prominent
cues called Interaural Time
Differences, ITDs, and
Interaural Level Differences,
ILDs.
OK, so we'll talk about what
those are, how big they are.
We'll talk about performance
for localizing sounds in humans.
How good are we at
doing that task?
We'll have some demonstrations.
One of them I'm going to
give you in the room here
and the other three demos we'll
have to listen to in headphones
because we want to use just one
of these cues, interaural time
or interaural level differences.
And for the most part in a room,
in an ordinary environment,
they're mixed up together.
They come together.
But using headphones
we can isolate and play
just one or the other.
Then, we'll launch into
the neural processing
of one of these cues, ITDs, in
a part of the superior olivary
complex called the Medial
Superior Olive, or the MSO.
And so just a
heads up here, last
lecture we were talking about
the neurons in the olive called
the medial
olivocochlear neurons.
Those are completely different.
They have nothing to do
with sound localization.
So those were the MOC neurons.
And today, we're talking
about MSO neurons.
These are completely different.
They're neurons in a major part
of the superior olive called
the medial superior
olive because it's
in the medial part.
And then finally, we'll
end up with a discussion
of the assignment.
We have a written
assignment for audition
that's due in a few weeks.
But it is based, in large
part, on today's lecture.
So it talks about the model of
neural processing in the MSO.
And another heads up.
I've added a tiny little bit
to the end of the assignment.
And we'll talk about
what I've added.
And that revised
assignment is now
posted on the course website.
We'll talk about that at
the end of today's class.
So sound localization
using binaural cues.
What are the two cues?
Well, they're the
interaural time differences
and interaural
level differences.
And this subject,
cat, is listening
to this sound source
at the black dot.
The sound source
is emitting sound.
And because sound doesn't travel
instantaneously through air,
the sound located off to
the right of the subject
strikes the subject's
right ear first,
and then there's a
little bit of time
before it gets around
to the left ear, which
is pointed away from the source.
OK, so if this sound source is
emitting a click as diagrammed
here, so this y-axis could
be the sound pressure
level at the subject's
right and left eardrums
as a function of time.
This is the time axis.
So obviously, the sound
source is off to the right.
The right ear is going to
receive the sound pressure
first.
And then a little bit
later, the left ear
will receive the sound source.
I mean, will receive
the click sound.
If the sound emitted is, instead
of a click, a continuous wave,
like a sinusoidal wave.
It'll be delayed the same
amount right versus left.
So here's the right ear
sound pressure level,
and then here is
the delayed version
that appears at
the left eardrum.
Just a delayed version.
So how much is the delay?
Well, it depends on things like
the velocity of sound in air.
Sound in air.
I think we had this in
the very first lecture.
340 meters per second in air.
Now, it depends a little bit
on the temperature of the air.
And it depends a little bit
on the barometric pressure,
but these factors
change at less than 1%.
So about 340 meters
per second in air.
So knowing how many meters
between the right and left ear,
you can calculate for various
positions of the sound source
the interaural time difference.
Now, if you have a big head,
so that the left and right ears
are separated very far
apart, obviously you're
going to get a bigger
interaural time difference
than if you have a
tiny, little head.
Like a mouse sort or a bat.
The smallest animals
have very close eardrums,
so they have very small
interaural time differences.
OK, now a couple
other things I should
say about both of these
cues, interaural time
differences and interaural
level differences,
is they help us detect
where the sound is coming
from in the azimuthal plane,
which is the horizontal plane.
So here's a schematic
of a person's head
with the left ear.
This is the front of the head.
And the right ear is
behind, so you can't see it.
And so azimuth is in
the horizontal plane.
And that's where
interaural time difference
changes as a
function of position.
The other plane perpendicular to
that is the plane of elevation.
So for me going straight
up and straight down
is the elevation of
the sound source.
And you can imagine if there's
a sound source straight ahead,
it's going to strike my two
eardrums at the same time
because the path length from
the source to the eardrums
is the same.
And if that sound
source moves up
from being straight
ahead to, say,
elevated from straight ahead.
But still, it's in the same
place relative to the eardrums.
The path from the sound
source to the two eardrums
is going to be the same.
So the ITD does not change
as a function of sound source
elevation.
So these binaural cues that
we're talking about here
do not change as a
function of elevation.
So how do we detect the change
in elevation of a sound source?
Well, we talked
earlier in the course.
I think in the
very first lecture
about the so-called
"pinna" cues.
And so we have these
external ears, the pinnae.
And they help us
greatly in detecting
sounds that differ in
elevation because they
put onto the sound spectrum some
very prominent peaks and nulls.
And those peaks and nulls
change as a function
of sound elevation.
So go back to the very first
lecture that I gave you
and review that.
And we read a paper where if you
distort the pinnae by putting
little plastic or clay
ear molds in your pinnae,
your detectability
of sound sources that
change in elevation goes to pot.
You can't do it anymore.
But if you go out and
re-experience sound
with those little
distortions of your pinnae
and come back in
a few weeks, you
can re-learn how
to detect changes
in sound source elevation.
And in those kinds of
things, two comments.
Number one, you
don't need two ears.
You can detect change in
sound source elevation
with just one ear, because
one ear has a pinna
and it works just
fine in changing
the spectrum from one ear.
And number two, your
sensitivity to small changes
in sound source elevation
is not very good.
So if you change the sound
source elevation of 10 degrees,
most people cannot
detect that change.
The minimum changes in sound
elevation that are detectable
are more like 30 degrees,
which is a pretty big change.
We'll see using the binaural
cues to detect changes
in sound source azimuth,
we're down to about one degree
using these binaural cues.
So they're much better.
You're much more
accurate in terms
of localizing sound in azimuth
than you are in elevation.
Secondly, I should
have mentioned here
when we had this time delay
for the ongoing signal,
like a sinusoid wave, that
is equivalent to a phase
difference.
The phase is what
engineers use to define
where and when a sinusoidal
source starts and ends.
So engineers talk
about a sinusoid
going through a 360 degree
phase for one cycle.
And so this sinusoid is
delayed about a quarter cycle
relative to the right ear one.
And so it has a phase
lag or a phase difference
of about 90 degrees.
So you can talk about
interaural phase differences
for continuous waveforms,
like sinusoids.
And you talk about them
in terms of the number
of degrees of phase difference.
And of course, to convert
from one to the other you
need to know the frequency
that you're talking about.
Because if you're dealing with
a high-frequency sinusoid that
goes back and forth
a lot of times,
you have to know that to
calculate the interaural time
difference.
But some of our demos
that we listened to
will quote the interaural
delay in terms of phase.
An interaural phase difference.
Now, the second cue is
interaural level difference.
And here's the same subject.
Here's the same sound source.
The sound is coming to
the subject's right ear
and it's a high level
there because there's
a direct pathway.
But the sound to get to
the left ear of the subject
has to go around
the subject's head.
And sound does
bend around a wall.
So I can go out in the
hall and I can say, class,
can you still hear me?
Yes, you can still
hear me, right?
The sound is bending around.
Of course, some of
it's reflecting.
Sound bends around,
but some sound
bends around more easily and
more effectively than others.
And obviously, this
sound bent around.
There's still sound at
the subject's left ear.
This should actually be
delayed because it took longer.
But the purpose here is
that it's lower in amplitude
and it's not vanishingly small.
So there's less sound over
the subject's left ear.
And this is the interaural
level difference.
This interaural
level difference,
as we'll see in just a
minute, depends greatly
on sound frequency.
Such that very
low-frequency sounds,
because they have
a long wavelength
relative to the object
they're bending around.
Because of their
physical characteristics,
they bend around very well.
And so the interaural level
difference, as we'll see,
is almost 0 for low frequencies.
For very high
frequencies, there's
a big, so-called sound shadow.
They don't bend around
an object the size of the
had very easily.
And so there's a big
interaural level difference
for high frequencies.
So we think of these cues
then as being very important
for high frequencies.
So let me just note
that down here.
So ILDs-- I'll use
a different color.
Important.
And let me show you some
data to support that then.
These are some data taken for
the two cues for a human head.
And how do we get these data?
Well, we can take
two small microphones
and put them down in our
ear canals very close
to our eardrums.
And we can measure the time
difference and the level
difference.
And so if you were
to do this, you'd
seat a subject in
an anechoic room.
An anechoic room is one that
doesn't have any echoes coming
off the walls and the ceilings.
So that the subject just
experiences the direct sound
from whatever sound source.
And the sound source we're
going to move around.
So this x-axis is the
sound source position
in angles from directly ahead.
So directly ahead is 0.
And higher angles is off,
let's say, to one side.
And directly off to
the side is 90 degrees.
And then behind the subject
is greater than 90 degrees.
And directly behind the
subject will be 180 degrees.
So this is degrees of
azimuth from directly ahead.
This top graph shows you the
interaural time differences
and the bottom graph shows
you the interaural level
differences.
So how do we compute time
from the microphone signals?
Well, we simply
take our microphones
and run them to an oscilloscope.
So here's the head.
Here's microphone 1 in the
ear canal on the left side.
Here's microphone 2 in the
ear canal on the right side.
You send the wires from those
two signals to an oscilloscope.
The top channel
will be the signal
coming from the left side.
The lower channel is the signal
coming from the right side.
And this device,
the oscilloscope,
plots the voltage, which is
equivalent to the pressure
as a function of time.
And we can measure the
time when this sound starts
and the delay, or
interaural time difference,
when the second ear starts.
So it's very simple to measure.
Now that said, it's
also very simple
to assume that the human
head is just a sphere.
And it's simple
to compute knowing
the distance
between the two ears
and the angle of
the sound source.
It's very simple to assume that
this human head is a sphere.
And I think this solid line
is assuming it's a sphere.
And the dashed line with x's
are the experimental data.
The data are pretty
close to the assumption
that the human head is a
sphere for interaural time
differences.
And here's the ITD plotted
as a function of the angle.
As you would expect if the
sound source is straight ahead--
that is 0 degrees
angle-- the ITD is 0.
The sound takes the same
time to get to the two ears
because it's straight ahead.
Now as you move the
sound over to one side,
it's going to get to one
ear first and the other ear
a little bit later.
And so the ITD
becomes bigger than 0.
And it goes up.
And the maximal
ITD, as you would
expect when the
sound is directly off
to the side, which
is at 90 degrees.
And what are the units here?
You probably can't read them,
but they go from 0 to 0.6.
And those units
are milliseconds.
So the ITDs go from
0 to 0.6 milliseconds
for the human head.
So millisecond is a
thousandth of a second.
It's pretty small.
It's less than 1 millisecond
for the maximum ITD.
And so you can quote this in
terms of microseconds as well.
So this would be a
total, a maximal ITD
of 600 microseconds.
OK.
Now, how about interaural
level differences?
They are in the lower panel.
And these are all
measured values.
They're not computed.
I don't know why, you
could compute them easily.
Maybe it's because of the pinna.
The pinna introduces
another piece of complexity
that's a little bit
different from the head
being an absolute sphere.
So these are measured.
And these are, again, plotted
as a function of the azimuth.
0 degrees is straight ahead,
90 degrees is off to one side,
and 180 degrees of azimuth
is behind the subject.
And these, I said the
ILDs depend on frequency.
So these are separate
plots for a bunch
of different frequencies.
Down at the bottom is a very
low frequency, 200 Hertz.
This is our standard
center of the human hearing
range, 1,000 Hertz.
And this is a very
high frequency
at the top, 6,000 Hertz.
And as you can see quite
clearly, a 200 Hertz,
like I said before,
this frequency of sound
bends around very
nicely for objects
the size of the human head.
And so even if you have the
sound source all the way
to the right, The ILD
for 200 Hertz is 0.
You don't have an
ILD, essentially,
for such low frequencies.
For our mid-human
hearing frequency,
the ILD starts out
at 0, straight ahead,
and climbs to perhaps 6 or 8 dB.
As the sound source
moves off to the side,
it's not behaving
like a perfect sphere.
So a perfect sphere,
the ILD would
go up and be maximal
at 90 degrees.
So maybe this is the
effect of the pinna.
This is not doing that, but
it's certainly climbing.
The biggest ILD is found at
these highest frequencies.
So for 6,000 Hertz,
the ILD climbs from 0
up to an ILD of
20 dB as the sound
is located off to one side.
And that's a huge cue for
localization of sounds.
So maybe you can remember
back to the very first
of my lectures, where we had
the decibel demonstration.
We changed decibel levels.
I think this was a
noise that we presented
in changing steps of 6 dB.
And it was clearly
obvious when you
change-- this is now
binaural level at 6 dB.
3 dB changes in noise
level were obvious.
A 1 dB change in noise
level as we stepped through
was obvious after you'd
gone through a few steps.
But maybe from one to the
next step was not obvious.
Clearly, a 20 dB difference
between the two ears
is a huge cue.
How can we confirm
that that's a huge cue?
Well, we can take a these
cues and present them
through headphones.
And it's very easy
to set up a circuit
so that you have a signal
coming into the two headphones.
And in one channel,
you put a device
called an attenuator that
attenuates the signal.
So why not use an amplifier
that amplifies the signal?
Well, amplifiers
are active devices.
And if you amplify
sounds, inevitably you
add a little bit of distortion.
So it's easier to just
attenuate the sound.
Attenuators are
passive devices and you
can cut the sound
to one channel 20 dB
and it sounds like
a huge effect.
And you say, oh, wow.
That sound disappeared
in one ear.
It sounds like it's
coming from the other.
You can cut the sound
by 6 dB, a huge effect.
Cut it by 3 dB, a big effect.
And you cut it by
1 dB and the person
says, well, before when the
sound was the same in the two
ears, the sound
was straight ahead.
When you changed it 1 dB,
it sounded like it just
moved a little bit
from straight ahead.
So it turns out that 1 dB is not
only our just detectable level
in sounds when we present
them to the two ears,
but when we vary the
interaural level difference.
So 1 dB is our just
noticeable difference for ILD.
OK, we can play that
trick with headphones.
Do good tests on that.
So clearly, these cues are very
important at high frequencies
because they're
the salient cues.
What about at low frequency?
Since we don't have an
interaural level difference,
you would assume that we're
going to use interaural time
differences at low frequencies.
And you'd be correct.
Much of the evidence
suggests that ITDs
are used at low
frequencies and ILDs,
because they're big at
high frequencies-- those
are the cues used there.
And why don't we use
ITDs at high frequencies?
OK, there is nothing in the
physical characteristics
of sound.
For example, the sound velocity
doesn't depend on frequency.
It's constant no matter what
the frequency of the sound.
So you're going to get the
same ITD for low frequencies
and for high frequencies.
Well, if you think
about it a little bit,
there is a reason where
high-frequency ITDs
are less useful.
At some frequencies,
this sound waveform
is going to go back
and forth so quickly
that it might hit the right ear.
And then by the time it
leaks around to the left ear,
it goes through
a complete cycle.
Then, what are we left with?
We're left with right and
left looking exactly the same.
There's a big time difference,
an interaural phase difference
of 360 degrees.
But we'll never be
able to perceive
that because the
sound is, again,
the same at the two ears.
And it turns out,
of course, that
depends on how widely
spaced your ears are.
For the size of a
human head, the phase
goes completely
through one cycle
at a frequency of 1.6 kilohertz.
And that's pretty centered
in your hearing range.
1 kilohertz is about the
middle of your hearing range.
1.6 is pretty close.
So above 1.6 kilohertz,
ITDs become ambiguous.
And so we think of that as
the time where ITDs fall out
and ILDs become important.
So ITDs are ambiguous for
humans above 1 kilohertz.
Now, that argument, of course,
is for ongoing interaural time
differences.
If you start the sound,
no matter what frequency,
you're going to have
an onset difference.
You can start a 2
kilohertz sound.
The left ear will get it first,
and then the right ear a little
bit later, depending
on where it's
located and the degree of
separation of your two ears.
But that's just one cue.
And if these things are repeated
back and forth thousands
of times, depending
on how long they're
on for, for low-frequency
sounds you'll
get those thousands of cues.
But for high frequencies,
you'll just get the onset.
So for high frequencies, we
think of these frequencies
as not being useful for
ITDs for these ongoing cues,
like interaural
phase differences.
OK, is that clear?
Any questions?
All right.
Let's see how good we are
in terms of performance.
Sound localization is
accurate and humans
have excellent performance.
How do we measure
such performance?
Well, we take an observer.
We sit them down in a
room or in free field
where there's only the
direct sound coming
from the sound source.
And no reflections off
the walls or echoes
off the ceiling or floor.
And we say to this
observer, OK, here's
the sound directly ahead.
And then we move
the sound source.
And this can be a
physical speaker.
We move the speaker
over a little bit
and so we change azimuth.
And we ask the person, was
that azimuth detectable?
We say, is that the same or
different from straight ahead?
So if straight ahead is here
and we move the speaker over
to here and we say to the
person, same or different?
Same position or
different position?
And the person says, yeah, sure.
That's different.
And then we instead say,
OK, straight ahead is here
and we're going to move it less.
The person says, sure,
I can detect that.
No problem.
It moved off to the right.
And this is, again,
without any visual cues.
So the speaker has to
be behind a screen.
So it's only auditory
cues that allow
you detect this
change in movement.
So we do it a third
time, straight ahead,
and we move it such a small
degree that the person says,
I don't hear that change at all.
And we titrate the
level of movement
until we get what's called
the minimum audible angle
in degrees.
And we can do that for a whole
bunch of different frequencies.
And when we do that
with sound sources,
such that the initial position
is 0 degrees straight ahead,
we get this curve linked
by the black dots.
Such that at low frequencies,
the minimum audible angles
approach, in the
best performance,
1 degree of azimuth.
An observer can
tell the difference
between 0 degrees straight ahead
and 1 degree to the right or 1
degree to the left.
It's very impressive
performance.
In the middle frequencies,
where the ITDs
are starting to break
down and become ambiguous,
our performance is not so good.
Minimum audible angles go
up to perhaps 3 degrees.
And then they get
a little bit better
at the very high frequencies.
And remember here, we said
that the interaural level
differences were very salient.
So at 5 kilohertz, there
was a 20 dB difference.
And we come back down,
maybe not to 1 degree
minimum audible
angle, but maybe to 2.
So almost as good.
And then at very
high frequencies,
we get worse again.
Now, we can take
these same subjects
and we can go back
to the physical cues.
Let's say at a 1 degree
minimum audible angle
at low frequencies where
ITDs are important cues, what
is the interaural time
difference that a subject can
just barely detect?
Well, if you had a
magnifying glass,
you could read it
off this curve.
Because 1 degree is a very
small angle on this scale.
But you can calculate it
from the sphere, right?
And it turns out
that the prediction
is that for the minimum
audible angle of 1 degree,
the interaural time
difference is 10.
Now, this is microseconds.
It's calculated to
be 10 microseconds.
Where we perform the best,
where we're using ITDs,
this minimum audible
angle, change
in sound source of
1 degree corresponds
to a change of ITD
of 10 microseconds.
That seems like an unbelievably
small instant in time.
But once again, if you
take the subject and now
instead of an attenuator
in one channel,
you have a circuit that delays
one ear relative to the other.
And you say to the
subject, OK, with no delay,
what did it sound like?
Straight ahead.
OK?
Then you put your
delay in and you
say, what does it
sound like now?
And the subject says,
it just barely sounds
like it moved a little
bit off to one side.
And in fact, 10 microseconds is
the just noticeable difference
for ITD in headphones,
which is evidence then
that we are using these
ITDs at the low frequencies
for sound localization.
Now, you can, as we said,
play the same trick here.
Minimum audible
angle at 2 degrees.
Go to the ILD curves.
And I'll try to get your
magnifying glass out here
at 5 kilohertz.
Look at where 2 degrees is.
And it turns out that the
interaural level difference
there is 1 dB.
Play it in headphones.
The subject says,
yeah, it sounds
like it's just a
little bit off center.
So it all fits with these
presentations in free fields
and these interaural level
cues measured in free fields
with what you get in headphones.
Now, we have some
demos of these things.
And I have several
kinds of demos.
So let's do the
real fun one first.
The problem with fun demos
is sometimes they don't work.
So this has worked
in some classes
and has not worked
in other classes.
I have a sound source.
It has a lot of
high frequencies.
You can probably appreciate
that, jangling keys.
And I would like to
be able to just say,
OK, I'm going to just give you
interaural level differences.
Probably, that's
what you'll get here
with high frequency sounds.
But I can't assume
that it's also not
going to have some ITDs
because in this room
there's going to be
differences in time
from the sound source
to your two ears.
So I'm really going
to give you both cues,
but let's start with this demo
before we go on to headphones.
I'm going to jangle these keys.
And I'm going to
ask you, because you
are such visual people,
to cover your eyes while I
jangle the keys.
Don't cover yet, because
what I want you to do
is to tell me where
the keys are coming
from with your other hand.
I want you to point where you
think the keys are coming from.
And at the end, after you
hear the sound, keep pointing,
and look and see
how good you were.
OK?
So everybody, cover your eyes.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK?
Now, uncover your eyes
and keep pointing.
OK, so we're doing
pretty well here.
Maybe 20 degree angle, but
most of you guys are on.
All of you guys are on.
All right, let's
do it once more.
So blindfold yourself.
Going to move the
position of the keys.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK, open your eyes
and keep pointing.
OK, you guys are good.
Maybe like 20 degrees.
I changed the elevation
a little bit too,
so you guys are making
mistakes in elevation.
You guys are good.
OK.
Now, since I claimed to you
that we're using two ears,
I would like you to plug
one ear, blindfold yourself.
Now, it's going to be a little
bit of a trick to point, right?
So I don't know how
you're going to point.
You can point with
your elbow or you
can do whatever
you want to point.
AUDIENCE: Close your eyes.
PROFESSOR: You can
close your eyes.
OK, if you're truthful.
You can close your eyes, OK.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK, open up and we'll
see how you did.
You guys are good.
There's an error.
That's the biggest
error I've seen so far.
This is an error, like
at least 45 degrees.
This is an era here.
So we're doing more poorly.
Let's plug the other ear
and I'll repeat the sound.
OK, close your eyes.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK, open your eyes
and keep pointing.
These are some errors.
Oh, this is a big error.
This is an error.
OK, so we're clearly,
anecdotally, getting worse.
OK.
Now, the ultimate
test, plug one ear.
And in your remaining
ear, distort your pinna
because I claimed that your
pinna cues were helping you.
And I really don't know how
you're going to point here.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK.
Now, open.
Just continue to
point if you can.
OK, so that's a 90 degree error.
You guys are pretty good.
You have an error here.
You guys are good.
This is an error.
And where were you pointing?
You were pointing
correctly, yeah.
So good.
OK.
Let me try it one more time with
distorting pinna and plugging
one ear.
[KEYS JANGLING]
OK, show me where
you were pointing.
You guys are good.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
PROFESSOR: This is a
little-- was it harder--
AUDIENCE: It's impossible.
PROFESSOR: It's impossible.
So you were guessing?
That's why it doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: It all
sounds the same.
It all literally
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It all
sounds the same.
PROFESSOR: It all sounds the
same with the pinna distorted.
Right.
OK, this is a huge error.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think it worked.
Pinna is very important
in distinguishing front
versus back.
Interaural time and
level differences
are equivalent for
front and back.
So how do we know
what's front and back?
Well, the pinna cues are
very important for that.
Otherwise, you have
subjects reporting
confusion between
front and back.
A lot of the times to eliminate
front-back confusions,
experimenters will
require subjects
to point in the frontal
[? hemisphere. ?]
And say, it's not in the back.
I give you that
it's in the front.
OK, so we have more
control demonstrations
that can be presented
during headphones.
And we have demonstration
of these two cues.
And there are three
demonstrations.
So the first two
demonstrations are ITDs.
And the first one uses tones.
So a tone is a sine wave.
And it's going to give you tones
of 500 Hertz and 2,000 Hertz.
So the low frequency
and higher frequency
are heard with alternating
interaural phases
of plus and minus 45 degrees.
So let me just remind you, we
saw here an interaural phase
difference of about 90 degrees.
So this is going
to be half of that.
Interaural phase
differences of 45 degrees
for these 2 pure tones.
The second one for ITDs
is going to use clicks.
And they're going to be repeated
just like my hand clapping.
Next, the interaural arrival
time of a click is varied.
And it doesn't tell
you how big the ITD is.
The apparent location of
the click appears to move.
And to me, it sounds like
the clicks are going around.
Somebody clapping their hands
moving around in a circle.
Now, when you listen to these
demos with earphones or ear
buds, sometimes you
get the impression
that wherever it's
coming from, it's
sort of like on the
surface of your head.
It's not way out there.
That may be because
you have lost
some of the room acoustics.
Certainly, you're not
listening to reflections.
But you've also lost the
effects of the pinna, which
filter things in
such a way that they
sound more roomy or out there.
These things sort
of sound internal,
but they still appear
to change in azimuth.
And I think this click
demonstration is the most vivid
of the three.
The final demonstration is
interaural level differences.
The overall interaural
level difference
of a 100 and 4,000
tone is varied.
Now, heads up here.
This low-frequency
tone is never going
to have an ILD in normal
free-field acoustics.
It's just never going
to happen because
of the size of your head.
You have to have a huge
head to cause a sound shadow
for that low of a frequency.
But you can certainly just-- as
easily as for high frequencies,
present that in headphones.
And it is perceptually
obvious, OK?
So there's these three demos.
So how many people have
them on your machines
and have earphones?
OK, so you guys can
just go right ahead.
How does it appear?
Are they in order?
Do they have names?
AUDIENCE: You can just
download them from Stellar.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can download them from
Stellar if you haven't already.
They should be on
the course website.
So just do them in sequence.
People who don't have
them on their laptops
can listen up here.
I have these listening stations.
So whoever wants to come
up and listen can come up.
Could you hear them
going around your head?
That's, to me, the most vivid.
Comments about the others?
This last one is
kind of piercing
for the high frequency, right?
And it still sounds
like it's moving around.
What about for this
lower frequency?
Did it sound like it
was moving around?
OK, even though
that stimulus is not
present in free-field sound.
You will never hear
that without headphones.
It's perceptually obviously.
Now, how about this ITD?
To me, this 500 Hertz interaural
phase difference is obvious,
but the 2,000 Hertz wasn't.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Clear for you.
Any speculation on why
that would be true?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, what
we're saying is then
that this is the left
ear for the low frequency
and the right ear is, what?
45 degrees?
So it's going to be
sort of like this.
OK, that's for maybe
the lower frequency.
And the higher frequency is
quite a bit higher, right?
It's more than
twice the frequency.
So it's more than twice as much.
I'm a terrible
artist, but it's going
to go back and forth faster.
And this is going to
be delayed 45 degrees.
So because this is
going faster, it's
a smaller time difference
for the high frequency.
So you might say, OK, it's
just a smaller time difference.
And that's why it's harder
for us to distinguish it.
But remember the concept
that we had of phase
locking of the auditory nerve.
In the auditory nerve,
the left auditory nerve
is going to fire some spikes
at some point in the stimulus
waveform.
The right auditory
nerve is going
to fire some spikes at
a corresponding point
in the stimulus waveform
for the first cycle.
OK, let's repeat it
for the second cycle.
Going to fire in
there somewhere.
This one's going to
fire in there somewhere.
And remember, cycles are
going by pretty quickly.
There's lots of time.
So you can build up
a response pattern
where you have
thousands of spikes
there, thousands of spikes here.
And these two auditory nerves
are coming into the brain.
They're synapsing in the left
and right cochlear nucleus.
Cochlear nuclei.
The cochlear nuclei are
then projecting centrally.
And at some places, the left
and the right-side pathways
converge.
There's a comparator then that's
comparing the arrival time
and it's saying the left ear
signal is getting to me first
and the right ear is
a little bit delayed.
What happens with
the higher frequency?
So this is an interesting
high frequency.
This is the 2,000 Hertz.
What happens to
the phase locking
for frequencies
above 1,000 Hertz?
It declines, right?
So instead of a nice
synchronized pattern,
this left auditory nerve
is going to respond.
The right is going to respond.
But from successive
cycle to cycle,
the pattern is not
going to be synced
to a particular point in
the stimulus waveform.
So instead of getting a
nice synchronized pattern,
it's going to be unsynchronized.
And maybe for some
stimulus presentations,
the right-side spike
is going to come
in earlier than the left side.
And the comparator
is going to say, WTF.
I don't know where the
sound is coming from, right?
So the fact that phase
locking breaks down
means that the timing at
wherever the central comparator
is, it's not synchronized.
Timing here is synchronized.
The timing here is
not synchronized.
And we're claiming with
this psychophysical metrics
that we can detect a
difference between the left
and the right ear minimally
at 10 microseconds.
With synchronized
patterns at least.
Now, let me just draw--
it's not too surprised.
Everybody understands why when
you break down phase locking,
you don't have a
temporal code anymore?
Let me show you the spike
waveforms for one spike coming
in in the left
side and one spike
coming in the right
side that are delayed
by this minimal time
of 10 microseconds.
So here is spike, let's
say the left side.
So to draw a spike coming in
from the right side delayed
10 microseconds, I need to
know the time base here.
How long does it
take a spike to fire
in the central nervous system?
What is the duration here?
What's the time scale here?
AUDIENCE: 1 millisecond.
PROFESSOR: 1
millisecond, very good.
OK, so now I'm going to draw
a right-side spike coming
in that's delayed
by 10 microseconds.
And it's pretty easy to do.
I'm going to do it
in a different color,
but it overlays
here very clearly.
I didn't draw anything because
on this time [? base, ?]
they're almost perceptually
indistinguishable.
OK, so the right side here
delayed 10 microseconds.
That's the wonderful
property of this system
that we have relatively
large, long inputs coming
into the CNS.
And we can, at the
limits of our perception,
distinguish delays of
a very short time scale
on the order of 10 microseconds.
That's the impressive nature
of this central comparator,
wherever it is.
And we're about to talk
about where it is now.
So let's look at where
it is in the brain.
We had our block diagram of
the central auditory pathway
before.
And here's kind of a
simplified diagram.
This is the left side
and the right side
of the brainstem with the
two auditory nerves coming
into the two cochlear nuclei.
And in the cochlear
nuclei, we discussed
that the auditory nerve
synapses and cochlear
nucleus neurons then
pick up the message.
Now, in one sense the
cochlear nucleus neurons
know only about what's going
on on that side of the brain,
or that auditory nerve.
They're not getting inputs
from the other side.
So they're not
binaural, if you will.
The first places where
you have binaural input
in the auditory
pathway are centers
like the superior
olivary complex.
And we talked about that before,
Superior Olivary Complex,
or SOC, having a bunch of
not only binaural inputs
but a bunch of
different sub-nuclei.
That's why it's
called a complex.
One of the most important
of those sub-nuclei
is the Medial Superior
Olive indicated here by MSO.
And the MSO gets input from
the left cochlear nucleus
if it's the left MSO.
And it also gets input from
the right cochlear nucleus.
And here is a very
good guess, at least,
for where the
central comparator is
on the basis of interaural
time differences.
And this was appreciated
from very early time point.
If you draw MSO neurons here,
they have two dendrites.
One's going to the left side,
one's going to the right side.
And they get numerous synaptic
inputs onto each dendrite.
If you make a lesion, so you
interrupt the inputs coming
from, for example, the
right side, all the inputs
onto the right
dendrites drop off.
So it looks like
all these inputs
are coming from the right side.
They've dropped off when
their pathway has been cut.
And the left ones remain
because their pathway is intact.
So clearly, the MSO neurons
get input from the two sides.
Now, way back in the
1940s, a psychologist
whose name was Lloyd
Jeffress proposed the model
for detection of the ITDs.
And he guessed at several
locations in the brain
where this model could
actually be present.
And one of his guesses
was in the MSO.
And it turns out the MSO was the
correct of his several guesses.
And this is a very
interesting model
for neural processing of ITDs.
And it has several
important assumptions.
First, the MSO receives
input from the left
and the right side, as
we have just gone over.
So these are axons coming
in from the left side.
And these are axons coming
in from the right side.
And the dots there are the
MSO neurons themselves.
The dots are very
fussy kind of neurons.
They don't just
respond to any input.
They're very discerning.
They say, OK, I got some
input from the left side.
Not a big deal.
We get some input
from the right side,
I'm not going to get
excited about that.
But I'm going to get very
excited if I get input
from the left and the right
side at the same time.
That is, coincidentally.
And so the MSO
neurons are sometimes
called coincidence detectors.
That is, they detect
and they respond only
when they get coincident
input from the left
and the right side.
Well, how's that
going to help us
if we're delaying one
side versus the other?
Well, the second major
component of the Jeffress model
is that the axons providing
input, which we now know
are coming from the
cochlear nucleus,
they run down the
length of the MSO.
And as they run down the
length, they give off branches
to each MSO neuron in this long
chain going from left to right.
And if you know anything about
spikes that are traveling down
axons or nerve
fibers, you'll know
that the spikes
don't get instantly
to the very tip of the axon.
But it takes them time
to travel down the axon.
And so for example in this axon,
the impulse is coming down here
and it gets to this
leftmost branch first.
And then a little
bit later in time,
it gets to the next branch.
And so on and so
forth until it gets
to the rightmost branch
at the longest delay.
So Jeffress said, the inputs
to the MSO are, if you will,
delay lines.
That is, axonal impulse
propagation takes time.
You can set these lines up
so that they are delay lines.
The inputs on the right
have corresponding delays.
Now, how big are the delays?
And the flip side
of that question
is, how long does it take
impulses to travel down axons?
So another name for that is the
conduction velocity in axons.
Well, these are,
let's say, myelinated
axons of pretty big
size, like 5 micrometers.
So let's say they're
myelinated, a large diameter.
5 micrometers, let's say.
It turns out that such
a conduction velocity
for those kinds of axons is
about 10 meters per second.
And Jeffress was
sharp enough to know
that in the dimensions
of the brain,
those conduction
velocities work out
to predict about the
right delay for the kinds
of interaural time
differences that we're
talking about for sounds
that differ in azimuth.
So Jeffress, at the time he
was postulating his model
in the 1940s, there
were good measurements
of axonal conduction velocity.
And he realized that
these delay lines
were pretty good for
predicting or compensating
for the interaural
time differences.
Now, how does this model work?
Well, I have a little demo of
the model, which is a movie.
Which I have in a
different PowerPoint.
And I'm going to show
this coincidence model.
And I guess I didn't
credit the person who
made this movie,
which is Tom Yin.
And he works on the
auditory brainstem
and he's based at the University
of Wisconsin in Madison.
So what this demo will
show you is you'll
be looking down
onto the brainstem.
And the MSO on the left side and
the right side will be present.
The model is set up to demo
the MSO on the right side.
There will be a
cochlea on the left
and a cochlea on the right.
The auditory nerve coming
into the cochlear nucleus
on the left and
the auditory nerve
coming into the cochlear
nucleus on the right.
And those two nuclei will be
providing inputs to the MSO.
And action potentials,
or impulses, along
these nerve fibers
will be indicated
by little highlights--
little yellow lights.
And the demonstration
will show you
what happens to these
incoming impulses that
converge at the MSO for a
sound that's straight ahead.
So a sound that's
straight ahead will
strike the two
sides at the same--
will strike the two
pathways at the same.
And you'll see what
happens to the MSO
and which neuron in the
coincidence detector
array lights up.
Then, I think it'll play that
same demo in slow motion.
Then, the second part
of the demo I think
has the sound source displaced
off to the left side.
So the sound wave front will
come and strike the left side
first and the right
side after a delay--
the interaural time difference.
And you'll see what happens
to the impulses and the MSO
neurons with that second
sound source position.
So here are the two
cochleas, left and right.
Here is the MSO.
This is the right
cochlear nucleus.
This is the left
This is the MSO we're
not talking about.
This is the right MSO.
There was a sound wavefront
that hit the two sides equally.
And it was a little
hard to appreciate,
but I think this neuron up here
in this part of the MSO lit up.
This is going to be
the same wavefront
in slow motion activating the
two cochleas at the same time,
the two cochlear nuclei
at the same time,
and coming in to the MSO.
This one gets there first
because it's on the right side.
And the two impulses
arrive coincidentally
at MSO neuron number 2.
And that's the one, because it
gets coincident input-- that's
the one that fires off.
Here's a second part of the
demo where the sound is now
located off to the left side.
First, it's going to
show you in fast motion
and then in slow motion.
Left cochlea activates
first, right second.
And now, the MSO neuron
that got coincident input
is located down here,
neuron number 6 I believe.
Now, it's going to
show you that offset
sound source in slow motion.
Left cochlea gets activated
first, right second.
Left cochlear nucleus first,
right cochlear nucleus second.
Now, the delay
lines are set up so
that neuron number
six in the MSO
is the one that
responds because it now
is the one that gets
coincident input.
Is that clear?
So what you've set
up then in the MSO
is an array of neurons where
0 ITD is mapped up here
and left leading ITDs
are mapped down here.
You've mapped interaural
time difference
to position along
the MSO in the brain.
And that's the Jeffress model.
So the Jeffress model has
been tested experimentally
by going in and recording
from single MSO neurons.
So easy to say and extremely
difficult to do in practice.
It's not absolutely clear why.
It may be that the
MSO neurons are small
and there are thousands of
big inputs coming to them,
so that you get what
are called big field
potentials in your recordings
and very small spikes.
So the number of studies
of actual MSO recordings
can probably be listed on
the fingers of one hand.
So we don't have very much data.
What data we have
from MSO neurons
shows clearly that
the firing rate
is dependent on the
interaural time difference.
And that's what this
graph shows here.
I'm sorry it's not very
clear, but 0 interaural time
difference is right here
with the dashed line.
The firing rate is
plotted on the y-axis.
These dots over here
indicate the firing rate
for just left ear sound.
Or in the other one,
just right ear sound.
So there's not a very big
firing for presentation
of sound in just one
ear or the other.
That's consistent with
the Jeffress model.
Also, consistent
with the Jeffress
model is that if you
get a particular ITD
from the particular neuron
that you're recording from,
that neuron fires a great deal.
And other ITDs elicit
much less firing.
That is, the delay lines
didn't allow coincident input
to come and excite that neuron.
So firing rate that changes a
great deal as a function of ITD
is consistent with
the Jeffress model.
There, probably because
there's so few data,
the idea of this
mapping along the MSO
is not borne out by the
scanty experimental distance.
So we don't really
know that there's
a map as a function of a
particular brain distance.
This is the
anterior-posterior distance.
And they put this line here.
Really, the data are
all over the map.
So it's not clear that
there's an organized mapping.
It is clear that there's
a function of firing
when you change the ITD.
So there are some updates
to the Jeffress model.
And I'm not going to go
through these in detail,
but I want to point
them out to you
because this is part of the
answer to your assignment.
The assignment says, sort of
here's the Jeffress model.
Give me a quick outline of it.
So that's just what I said.
I've given you that part.
The second part says,
well, the Jeffress model
is maybe currently
under discussion.
What are new
experimental evidence--
new I mean from the
last 15 years-- that's
not perfectly consistent
with the Jeffress model?
And you should go
to this paper, which
is the assigned paper for
today's lecture, in which they
discuss point number
1, point number 2,
and several other points.
At least one other point is
demonstrated in that paper
to show some
experimental evidence
from MSO recordings
which is not perfectly
consistent with
the Jeffress model.
Or makes you think,
well, maybe they
Jeffress model is not
complete, or is outright wrong.
And these are recordings
from Brandt et al.
The earlier slide I showed you
was from recordings in Cat.
Cat has become less and
less the experimental model.
And these are now recordings
from smaller animals which
are more in vogue to
use experimentally.
In this case, it's
from the gerbil,
which is a popular animal.
It has a big MSO, good
low-frequency hearing
where you use
prominent ITD cues.
And this paper
clearly is a challenge
to the Jeffress model.
I don't think it
completely rules it out,
but clearly there are
some data from this paper
to suggest that it
might not be everything.
Now, the second part
of the assignment.
Actually, that's
the second part.
The third part of
the assignment comes
from some other
experimental data
that I'm not going to
give you because you
don't need to know about them.
But some labeling studies have
asked the question, OK, I'm
going to inject a neural
tracer into my cochlear nucleus
neuron.
I'm going to trace
its axon and I'm
going to find this
nice, ladder-like delay
line in the MSO.
Those labeling studies
haven't been particularly
gratifying in that they
don't fit this model so well.
I say here, at
first it was thought
that there were delay
lines from both sides.
Labeling studies suggest
that there is only
a delay line for
contralateral input.
OK, so that's not exactly
consistent with the Jeffress
model.
And even more recent
studies since I
wrote this suggests maybe there
aren't even delay lines at all.
So experimentally,
someone doesn't
see a delay line, that
doesn't mean it's not there.
It just means maybe
it's not so obvious.
But people have started
thinking about maybe
there are other ways to
provide delays in inputs
to the MSO that might make
the Jeffress model work.
If you have coincident
detectors and they
respond only when the delay a
certain ITD-- matches the ITD.
So the third part
of the assignment
asks you for other ways
that you can think of
to create delays to MSO neurons.
And let me give you a
couple hints to the answers
that I'm looking for.
I think you should think about
the synapse between the input
from the cochlear nucleus
to the MSO neuron.
How could you create
different types
of delays using
synaptic properties?
So this is kind of
a thought question
because these haven't
been measured yet.
Secondly, there is another
way to create delays.
And it comes from
properties of the cochlea.
And that brings us to
our reading for today.
We always have a reading.
The reading is from this
obscure document, also called
our textbook.
OK, and the reading
is on page 61.
Page 61 is the early
part of the book.
It's talking about
the ear, the cochlea.
It says, "But you may also note
that the vibration of parts
of the basilar membrane
tuned to frequencies below 1
kilohertz-- very low-- appear
time shifted or delayed
relative to those tuned
above 1 kilohertz.
This comes about because
of the mechanical filters
that make up the
basilar membrane.
They're not all in
phase with each other.
If you look at Figure 2.4--"
So everybody should look
at Figure 2.4 in the text.
So this is my devious
way of getting
you to actually
open the textbook.
You will see that the impulse
responses of the lower
frequency filters rise
to the first peak later
than those of the
higher frequency ones.
OK, so don't just quote the
textbook in your answer.
Tell me how you could get
a delay that would make up
for the interaural time
difference using this cochlear
property that's mentioned
in the textbook page 61.
And it's illustrated in
Figure 2.4 of the textbook.
That's another way people
are thinking of an alternate
to Jeffress delay lines.
And then finally,
because last time I
thought that it was
too easy-- you guys
are too smart-- I added
something to the assignment.
This fits with my son's view--
my son is in high school
and he says, teachers
love to load on homework.
The more, the better.
So I added something to
make this assignment more
challenging.
And here's what I added.
And so I think this has now
been posted on the website.
It doesn't add a great
deal of difficulty,
but I think it makes it
more relevant to our course.
I haven't updated this.
OK, well, look on the
website, course website.
I haven't updated
on my computer yet.
Look on the course website.
The very last part of
the assignment, there's
one sentence that says, how
would a cochlear implant user
have trouble using the Jeffress
model to localize sounds?
Even if the cochlear
implant user
had a cochlear implant in the
left ear and a cochlear implant
in the right ear?
And I think this
is a fair question.
We spent a lot of
time on our course
talking about cochlear implants.
And cochlear implant processing
is clearly very different
than we, as normal hearers,
have the processing
on our auditory nerve.
So think about that.
How would the
Jeffress model not be
able to be used very well by
a cochlear implant user who
had implants in the
left and right side?
So this is a written assignment.
I think before we talked
about how long it should be.
And I can't remember how--
maybe five pages is plenty.
In the very beginning, it
talks about the Jeffress model.
So give me a quick sketch.
It's due on December 4, which
is the day of the lab tour.
And you could send
them to me by email
or you can bring a printed
copy to the lab your.
Or, you can bring a
printed copy to my office,
but that's at Mass Eye and
Ear where the lab tour is.
And the idea behind
having it due then is
I can look them
over and grade them,
and then we can talk
about what I thought
is the correct answer to this
at the review session, which
is the class after December 4.